hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Spanish language black
comedy Anthology film called wild tale
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
in the opening scene we are introduced
to Isabelle a young fun-loving girl
about to fly to a different city for
work and co-passenger Caesar struggle to
place her bags in the overhead
compartments and offers to help this
starts a conversation between the two
and soon the Chit Chat leads them to
talk about their professions we find out
that the man is a classical music critic
in other words he makes fun of dead
people what an important job Isabelle
tries to keep the conversation going and
reveals that her first boyfriend was
also a classical musician named
Pasternak the name rings a bell in the
man's head and he remembers the worst
musical theory he was given to review
many years back the person who submitted
the theory was also named Pasternak the
man recalls how he dragged the theory to
the ground with his review and ended
pasternak's musical career that's fine
he later became a great hockey player
suddenly Isabelle looks at him in
Surprise revealing that they are talking
about the same person she was still
Pastor next girlfriend when the review
for his music theory came out and she
remembers how he didn't come out of his
room for three days after the review was
published just then an old woman in
another row gets intrigued by their
conversation she turns around and
discloses that Pasternak was her student
years ago in high school he is still the
most unique student she has had because
he wasn't good at anything the three
look at each other in surprise at The
Coincidence but the strange occurrences
don't end there a young man from a few
rows in front recognizes the old woman
as his high school teacher as it turns
out he used to bully Pastor Knack in
school the musical critic recognizes the
pattern and asks the other passengers if
any of them know someone named
pasternack when almost all of them raise
their hands it is clear that something
is wrong I'll tell you what's wrong
Pasternak is missing his surprise party
this is further proven when they find
out no one on the plane even paid for
their tickets some of them won it in a
lottery and others were sent by their
companies like Isabel was the music
critic asks Isabelle how her
relationship with Pasternak ended and
she discloses that she cheated on him
with his only friend who is also seated
a few seats back on the plane they
conclude that every passenger on the
plane has done something bad to Pastor
Knack and he has set them up to fly
together all at once as everyone begins
panicking a scared flight attendant
comes out and reveals that she was
forced to work today by pasternack who
is the cabin chief of the flight she is
worried because a few minutes ago the
pilots stopped responding and the door
to the cockpit is closed somewhere else
an old couple is enjoying the weekend by
the pool in silence their quality time
is interrupted by The Faint noise of a
flying airplane they do not think much
of it until they notice the plane coming
towards them the story ends seconds
before they are hit leaving the viewers
to assume the rest those old people must
have [__] with Pasternak the second
story in the series takes place in a
small Diner one stormy night a
politician named Juan arrives at the
empty Diner and the only server moza
welcomes him right off the bat Juan is
rude and sarcastic towards her he makes
comments about her lack of skills before
making his order Moses Stomps to the
kitchen tell telling the owner of the
restaurant that she hates that man
however it is not for the reason the
owner assumes it turns out that Juan
used to be a debt collector in Moses
Village a few years ago he fooled her
father into getting into a huge debt
which eventually got him killed not even
two weeks after the death he tried to
seduce her mother offering her a lot of
money because of Juan moza and her
mother had to move out of the village
and start a new life in the city when
moza comments that she wants to tell one
off the owner Alexis suggests her a
better option she wants to poison his
food and kill him moza shocked at her
boss's reaction asks her if she is being
serious in the following scene she goes
to one to see if he needs anything he
makes an unconventional request and asks
her to review his election poster this
is when moza finds out that the man is
running for the mayor of the Town Alexis
thinks this is all the more reason to
kill him because they would be doing the
city a favor in addition she has been to
jail before and knows that it is far
better than her life owning a Diner
still mosa refuses to kill anyone and
goes to Juan with his food returning it
to the kitchen she finds out that Alexis
poisoned it without her consent that you
look at Juan enjoying the meal in
anticipation but the poison doesn't seem
to affect him Alexis thinks it is
because the poison expires but wonders
if expired poison is more or less
dangerous next we see Juan's son join
him at the table for dinner mosa panics
because she doesn't want to kill an
innocent man she rushes outside and
throws the food at Juan but it is too
late because his son has already had
some of it Juan Burns an anger into
taxmosa ready to kill her but before he
does so Alexis thinks on her feet and
brutally stabs him to death the customer
is always wrong [__] mosa gets up from
the floor covered in the blood of her
enemy who is now dead in the last scene
she and Juan's son are being helped by
the paramedics while Alexis is arrested
by the police she doesn't show any signs
of remorse and is happy to go to prison
still better than a politician though at
least she didn't say she wasn't gonna
poison him before she poisoned him the
third story takes place on a design
deserted Highway a wealthy stuck-up
businessman named Diego is driving on
his own when he encounters another car
swerving past him enraged by the
driver's lack of driving skills Diego
yells racial slurs at him and gives him
the finger only a few miles away he gets
a flat tire and has to stop his car
right in front of a bridge he tries his
best to fix the tire but for some reason
the car doesn't start giving up Diego
calls a mechanic who will be there in
half an hour right after the call he
notices the car from earlier driving
towards him knowing that the driver
would want revenge Diego quickly gets
inside and locks the doors as he had
predicted the driver named Milan Parks
his car in front and backs into Diego's
car he goes on to bring out a hammer and
smash it several times into the
windshield Diego watches him in
frustration trying to control his anger
because he knows he can't do anything in
turn Milan takes his abuse further by
defecating on the car's windshield and
peeing on it after that he gets into his
car and suddenly Diego's car starts
working Pooh can pee at that game with
burning rage in his eyes he drives his
car into Milan's and pushes it off a
cliff before driving away in the
following scene we see Milan climbing up
the cliff having survived the crash he
runs after Diego but cannot keep up with
the car just when we think their
interaction has ended something takes
over Diego and he makes a U-turn aiming
to drive into Milan and kill him however
before he can he loses control of his
car and falls down the cliff like Milan
did the latter now has an upper hand he
breaks into Diego's vehicle with a
crowbar and gets into a fight with him
they struggle for a long time before
Milan manages to push Diego off the car
with the seat belt wrapped around his
neck he then sets fire to the gas tank
hoping the car will explode and take
Diego with it but before he can get off
the businessman gains control of his
position and holds him back back on the
bridge a mechanic arrives and Witnesses
a loud explosion before hurriedly
calling the police in the last scene the
police are examining the burnt car the
dead bodies are together which they
assume is because they were trying to
save each other the moral of that tale
is that roadside assistance takes too
long to get there the fourth short film
is about an engineer named Simon one day
after work he goes to a bakery excited
to buy a cake for his daughter's
birthday on his way out Simon notices
his car is missing and finds a parking
ticket on the ground it turns out that
he parked in a restricted Zone which he
could have never known because the curb
isn't painted yellow even though he is
getting late for the birthday party he
decides to go to the DMV office first to
file a complaint to his utter disbelief
he is asked to pay the parking and the
towing fee before he can make a
complaint about the unpainted curb he
tries to argue his way with the officer
but is dismissed on his way home Simon
is stopped by a traffic jam so his
daughter has to cut a cookie on her
birthday instead of the cake Simon's
wife Melissa is enraged by his
negligence to his family even when she
is explaining her disappointment Simon
keeps complaining about the lack of
regulations in their city in the end
Melissa asks for a divorce deciding she
can no longer be with him the following
day Simon visits the DMV office he had
again and is faced with the same problem
no one wants to take his complaint
before he pays for the mistake he didn't
make all this pent-up frustration comes
out as he hits the glass barrier with a
fire extinguisher he is arrested
immediately and the News makes it to
television the following day Simon's
lawyer bails him out and reveals that he
has been kicked out by his company for
ruining their image the same day he has
to be at the court to discuss who gets
custody of his daughter after the
divorce the case leans towards his wife
because he has no job at the moment to
solve this Simon immediately starts
looking for work but because of his
reputation no company wants to give him
a chance frustrated by the rejection he
curses out the receptionist at one of
the offices but karma catches up with
him quickly when he finds out his car
has been towed again this time he simply
takes a cab to the DMV office pays off
the ticket and brings his car back in
the next scene we see Simon enjoying
breakfast at a cafe his car is parked
outside again in a No Parking Zone but
this time even the curb is marked he
watches in silence as his car is towed
away for the Third time in two weeks
hours later a loud explosion startles
everyone in the DMV office and breaks
down half of the building it turns out
that Simon being an engineer fitted his
car with dynamite to teach the DMV
office a lesson his lawyer fights the
case in court claiming that the
explosion was accidental this gains
media attention in several cases of DMV
treating people unfairly come out in the
news at last Simon gets his revenge and
revenge for the thousands of people who
are treated indifferently by the DMV on
a daily basis in the last scene we see
him celebrating his birthday in prison
with his daughter and wife he is now an
icon for the public who lovingly call
him Dynamite the moral of that one is if
you got a problem with the government
just skip straight to the killing the
fifth Story starts at the break of dawn
when a young man named Santiago drives
home from a club he goes straight to his
parents room and wakes them up in a
hurry a few hours later they are
watching the news on the television
about a hit and run case it is revealed
that Santiago accidentally hit a
pregnant woman with his car and killed
both the mother and her unborn baby
these are getting darker as they go
aren't they Santiago's father romino is
a wealthy businessman willing to do
anything to save his son from going to
jail the family of three panics and
calls their lawyer telling him
everything that has happened and the man
promises to get them out of the
situation they are well aware that the
police will find the car sooner or later
hence there is no benefit in staying
quiet the lawyer is brainstorming ideas
when suddenly his eyes land on the
housekeeper Jose working outside in the
garden in the next scene romino and Jose
are sitting in front of each other in
his study room a worried Romeo tells
Jose everything about the accident and
offers him half a million dollars to
take the blame for his son if Jose
accepts the offer the lawyer swears he
will get out of prison in less than a
year in addition his family will not
have to worry about money a day in their
life Jose accepts the offer without
thinking about it twice next the lawyer
takes him to the wrecked car and makes
him leave his fingerprints all over the
steering wheel he is also asked to drink
a bit of whiskey to make the story seem
legitimate the police arrive right after
and the lawyer tells them the made-up
story Jose also admits to the crime but
the sheriff insists on looking at a few
more pieces of evidence before arresting
him he asks Jose to get inside the
wrecked car and instantly notices the
mirrors are arranged in such a way that
he cannot see through them this means
that someone way taller than Jose was
driving the car seeing that the truth is
about to come out the lawyer bribes the
sheriff and brings him to their side
romino is told that he will have to pay
them a few million bucks to get out of
the situation even Jose demands for an
expensive apartment annoying his boss
the four men Gather in romina's study
room to talk about their Cuts they try
to take advantage of the situation he is
in demanding an absurd amount for
different reasons suddenly romino loses
interest in the matter and tells
everyone to get out he is ready to let
his son go to jail then to fulfill their
demands the others think he is just
bluffing but when he goes into his room
and locks the door it is clear that he
wants to end the deal a few hours later
a crowd is gathered outside the house
having discovered where the killer lives
romino's wife tries to convince him
otherwise wise but the man remains
adamant then the lawyer comes to him
with another deal demanding only three
million dollars for each of them romino
as a true businessman brings the money
down to one million dollars and
finalizes the deal at last Jose is
arrested and brought out of the house in
a hood suddenly a man jumps out of the
crowd and attacks him hitting him until
he dies we find out that the man is none
other than the husband of the woman who
died in the accident that story had no
moral that story was stupid now for the
final story it takes place at a wedding
Romina and Dominic are getting married
after years of relationship and the
party's busting the guests have the time
of their lives singing dancing and
enjoying delicious food when everything
is going well suddenly Romina notices
her husband talking to a female
co-worker they seem to be flirting which
makes Romina feel uncomfortable she
quickly calls a number on her phone and
watches the woman as she picks it up
Romina freezes as she realizes that
Dominic has been cheating on her with
his co-worker she knows this because the
numbers she called belongs to Dominic's
alleged guitar instructor who he visited
frequently last month all Dominic knew
how to play was Wonderwall it was a dead
giveaway before she can react the DJ
initiates the start of the bride and
groom's first dance Romina takes this
opportunity to ask Dominic if what she
thinks is true at first he begs her to
just enjoy the party and not think about
unnecessary stuff but after she pushes
him repeatedly he admits to sleeping
with the woman he promises that he will
never do anything like that again but
Romina is too angry to listen to his
excuses she bolts out of the venue and
ends up on the roof of the building a
while later she is approached by a chef
who sympathizes with her Romina sees
this as an opportunity to take revenge
and starts making out with him boner
appetite when Dominic arrives he sees
his wife and the chef making love Romina
shows no regret and instead threatens
Dominic that she will take all his
property and leave him with nothing
Dominic falls to the ground vomiting
giving her an opportunity to go back to
the party she acts like nothing happened
in front of the guests and asks them to
enjoy themselves the party is filled
with laughter and dances once again a
while later Dominic arrives and is
pulled onto the dance floor before he
knows it Romina is pulling his mistress
to dance with her she goes absolutely
Manic and throws the woman into a glass
door in the middle of the dance in the
next scene the paramedics are on the
scene taking care of the women Romina
still acts like nothing is wrong and
hurries her friends to start the wedding
games they had planned Dominic finally
loses his cool and yells at her in front
of the guests his mother takes it
further and attacks the bride before
being pulled away the doctor sit
everyone down to measure their blood
pressure trying to calm the situation
just when the guests think the chaos has
ended Dominic gets up and holds a knife
he surprises Everyone by cutting the
wedding cake and taking a huge bite of
it [__] Dominic I thought you were
watching your calories at last he walks
up to his bride spreading his arms for a
wedding dance to everyone's surprise
they start making out on the middle of
the dance floor when things start
getting steamy they leave the venue
quickly leaving the newlyweds by
themselves the movie ends as the two
make love on the table that was supposed
to be for their cake subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching